I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky
yeah but I have never seen anything like
this
how much more ID
[Music]
yeah
my son it is your time
respect
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze I never
[Music]
right now cuz we
because we own you
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all what happens now determines what
happens to the rest of the world
[Music]
hey everybody the revolution will not be
televised there's a new surprise black
panther trailer let's break it down
there's a new round of that thort ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video this mostly hyping up some
of the new technology we get a much
better look at his energy costume which
is just a little more form-fitting it's
like Iron Man going from the mark 1
which is like really bulky down to one
of his more modular suits which is even
more powerful because he finds a better
energy source and if you couldn't tell
part of this costume actually forms
around him this is what it looks like in
the comics so it's sort of him doing the
Tony Stark thing where you wear pieces
of a costume in the full costume just
emerges from that I'm expecting the same
thing to happen with this iron spider
suit like Peter wears part of it and
then the helmet will just form around
him auda matically so you have to
imagine that Black Panther can sort of
outdo Tony Stark at his own game because
his little sister Cherie is one of their
leading scientists so she's sort of like
the Peter Parker science bro in training
of this part of the world only a little
bit more advanced
she just been added a little bit longer
than Peter Parker's been at it you have
to imagine she's a couple years older
than him Peter Parker in high school
she's somewhere around college age like
somewhere around her early 20s but the
other thing about this too is that they
explain a little bit about how they hide
Wakanda from the rest of the world - you
see this giant energy dome that sort of
cloaks it and makes it look like just a
normal part of the terrain so you look
at Everett Ross and he's like what else
are you hiding from me so the really
cool thing that they've revealed is is
what's going on with the villains so
kill monger has his own agenda and his
own golden version of the black panther
suit which is pretty freakin crazy the
really cool thing about the costumes are
this actually looks like the Marvel
Knights version of the Black Panther
costume but they both have a bit of gold
on it so I think that's really what
they're going for with Black Panthers
second costume that he wears and I'm
assuming that he enters infinity war
wearing this and then like Tony Stark
gets an upgrade in every single movie
he'll also get some costume upgrades
when we get to infinity war and Klaw has
his own agenda but they've aligned just
because they can help each other out the
enemy of my enemy is my friend but it's
not like he'll monger really likes
Ulysses Klaw
he's still viewed as an outsider but in
the great way that Andy Serkis does he
tried to explain his villain like all
great movie villains they don't think of
themselves as villains so he wants to
expose what he sees as the hypocrisy of
wakanda which sounds like something a
villain would say like you know Black
Panther from the comics he's a good
character he funds captain Marvel's
Ultimates he works with the Avengers to
save the world but like he'll monger
says he wants to burn everything down
and change the world so obviously things
have gone to [ __ ] and because of their
vibranium they can be the world power
that he wants them to be but I think on
a fundamental level black panther
understands that if everybody around the
world good people and the bad people
were to get their hands on their
vibranium it would just end terribly for
everyone it would wind up looking like
this scene from Tony Stark's nightmare
and Avengers age of Ultron before Thanos
even got here so what I'm actually
really hoping for I talked about this in
my infinity war video that I posted last
night about everybody's upgrades is that
Shuri actually helps Tony Stark out a
little bit in the integrate some of
Black Panthers technology into his
designs too but that's a little further
off and even black panther in the comics
doesn't like to share a lot of this
technology like he's still very
mistrustful of the other Avengers
because of Tony Stark's history as a
weapons manufacturer but the big fight
that they're hyping up in this when kill
monger sort of sheds his clothing and
his black panther costume manifests is
that they're fighting for the leadership
of Wakanda because he hasn't officially
become keen yet even though he has his
father's ring you have to remember that
Wakanda is a big place with several
cities the one that we see them
traveling to at the beginning of the
trailer is just the main city where the
Royal Palace is there are several other
tribes this green person as well as man
ape who you see right here they're the
leaders of some of the other biggest
tribes so the whole idea here is is that
the Kingdom might wind up turning
against Black Panther if he makes a bad
move so that is what provides kill
mongers opportunities so it's not like
Black Panther has this stranglehold on
the kingdom and everybody loves him
there's a growing population of
wakanda's that are very dissatisfied
with what's going on inside the kingdom
so trouble from within and trouble
from outside with people like ulysses
klaw but you're starting at the
beginning of the trailer going through
the rest of the stuff Danai gurira is
sort of the leader of the door milosh a
the way that movies work I wouldn't be
surprised that they developed some sort
of ship between her and black panther he
has a couple of people that he falls in
love with in the comics but because they
can't do storm I don't think they're
gonna try and do that but you can always
hope for that x-men crossover
this is Ramon de his stepmother she's
sure he's natural-born mother
so remember Black Panthers father was
king for a long time
his first wife who was Black Panthers
mother died he remarried remonda
they had Cherie so sure he's only his
half-sister but you can see that he's
still very close to her like they have
that awesome handshake and she shows him
that really cool new black panther suit
these are the warrior falls this were
they have rites of passage so this is
where kill monger makes his initial
challenge to him and then it sort of
spills over into this area over here the
other really cool thing about this is
that they walk around a lot of the
different parts of the city so you just
get a much better look for whatever
thing is like they have that really cool
scene where he drops out of the plane
and uses those special energy spheres to
stop his kinetic energy so yeah it just
looks really badass but they halt his
descent they actually do serve a really
important purpose so you could jump out
of an airplane and they would stop you
from going splat on the ground so he
doesn't need to use a parachute like
normal people would and he doesn't have
repulsors like tony stark so this scene
right here actually looks like it's from
a different part of the trailer and
they've just cut it in a misleading way
so like he's wearing his old Civil War
black panther suit but in the big car
chase he's wearing the new suit so this
is probably from that other beginning
part of the trailer where he's taking
down the people in the jungle this is
also probably one of the coolest parts
of the trail that we haven't seen before
so he's looking at all of these Panther
spirits in the tree here this is sort of
their version of the afterlife it's sort
of this limbo state where he'll probably
get to talk to his father in spirit form
so like they said death is more of a
jumping-off point they'll probably
explain that in this movie and I am
curious how they're going to tie some of
these concepts to an infinity war
because there are some things that we
could talk about when it comes to
infinity gems but we'll have to wait for
that till after Thor
Ragnarok comes out so I'll explain that
at the end of the video a little bit but
in the comics there is an actual Panther
God from which he derives his powers he
has a special connection to it but
there's also the heart-shaped herb so
they'll probably explain both of those
things and how they work together to
make him the Black Panther
so like he'll monger can wear a black
panther costume he has the same enhanced
strength that Black Panther does but he
doesn't have the connection to the
Panther God so there are all these
things that work together to give him
his abilities there's technology there's
this special chemical compound in the
herbs that he eats and then there's the
spiritual aspect to it
shuri driving what looks like a really
badass vibranium enhanced car this
actually looks like a normal car that
she's doing something to with her
technology it actually looks like
they're fighting inside the vibranium
mines of Wakanda like you can see the
mineral deposits behind them so
obviously it's a really big place we're
gonna see every last bit of it so this
is probably going to be one of the final
big fights of the movie the other thing
you'll notice about this is that Klaw
actually gets his arm cannon that he has
from the comics but it's Inspector
Gadget style like it's a normal hand
that just pops out and turns into a
weapon so there's a lot of stuff in this
trailer that it looks like it just took
them a while to finish the CG on but
remember the Black Panther is coming out
of February in Black History Month so
there will be more trailers with even
more cool stuff so what's gonna happen
next this is my non-spoilery thor
ragnarok review we'll post on Thursday
no spoilers so don't worry about that I
have some new flash coming later tonight
I'll say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner angel Chavez please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to watch all the
Avengers get their hardcore armor
upgrades before infinity war and you can
click here for that new mutants trailer
again thank you so much for watching
everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight